[Music]
the new
eighth generation of the world famous
pokemon game has just been announced
with the release date set for late
2019 and i am offended why am i offended
you might ask pokemon is a beloved game
and the next gen has just barely been
announced all we have is a trailer which
tells us that the game will be taking
place in a new great britain themed
region
and we have been briefly introduced to
the three starter pokemon
clearly i couldn't have possibly
actually played the game so how can i
judge it and even be offended by it
already what are you
new to the internet everyone knows that
the first person to get triggered over
something is automatically the most
woke and what is more woke than getting
offended by something you barely know
anything about before
it even comes out a bunch of anime news
network
reviewers got extremely triggered when
the first episode of the shield hero
anime came
out and i made a video about that whole
thing so feel free to check it out while
it's still up because i'm currently
fighting a false copyright claim on it
and it might go down any day
link in the description but come on
getting offended
over something you barely know anything
about after just
one episode that isn't nearly
woke enough these days being the first
to be offended over
literally nothing has become social
currency on the internet
and if you do get offended first you'll
have a bunch of like-minded people
thanking you on twitter for enlightening
them as to why they should
be offended yet again over yet another
pointless thing
and i know what you must be thinking
animak
is this entire video a parody of people
who have no real meaning in their lives
and no true sense of identity or
self-confidence
so they spend their time looking for
things to be outraged about in order to
reinforce their own perceived victim
status within digital echo chambers of
like-minded insecure outraged addicts
yes it 100 is or or
you're just not woke enough to see how
absolutely
totally serious and important this video
is
so why should you be offended by pokemon
just like i am
well first of all you ain't rapped long
enough but second of all
everyone knows that pokemon amounts to
virtual dogfighting
pokemon brainwashes little kids into
thinking that they should use
shiny rocks on their household pets in
order to evolve them into vicious
killing machines
and if that wasn't bad enough pokemon
teaches kids that forcing their innocent
pets to brutally fight each other will
be rewarded with
money and glory even peta has criticized
pokemon for promoting
virtual animal cruelty and everyone
knows that peta would never say
anything hilariously stupid or moronic
so this proves that i'm right and if you
disagree
you are part of the problem clapping is
fun
but not only is pokemon as a whole
totally
super mega offensive but this new
pokemon sword and shield
is literally the worst of all ever
literally
what is a sword a dangerous violent
weapon that promotes
war and killing every year there are
people who get hurt
and die because of sword violence i mean
probably not as many as back in the
middle ages and stuff but some
is still one too many and what is a
shield
clearly it is a reference to the rising
of the shield hero
an anime that promotes literal slavery
and misogyny
and probably racism it's always good to
sprinkle one or two racism allegations
in there for good measure
so if you play pokemon sword and shield
you are supporting enslaving innocent
animals that don't exist you are
promoting
literal violence that isn't real and you
hate all women
and if you happen to be a woman who
plays pokemon then you're even worse
because you have
internalized misogyny do better and
don't even get me
started on the united kingdom slash
great britain inspired
new pokemon region did you know that at
some point
in history great britain was an empire
great britain promoted imperialism
colonialism
and slavery and everyone knows that if
you even reference anything remotely
related to these ideas in fiction you
are
literally condoning all of these things
like do i even have to mention
this stuff in the current effing year
please get woke sure this new pokemon
game may look
good and fun and colorful and cute but
have you tried altering the trailer to
make it black and white slowing it down
and then playing ominous music
over it
yeah think about it jar jar binks is
a sith lord and again you might be
thinking ha ha
what a ridiculous video animak everyone
knows that this is a parody satire blah
blah blah
it's just a prank bro no you are just
super lucky that you have the privilege
of enjoying games like pokemon without
considering the devastating implications
that these horrible games have on animal
rights
on gender equality and on not promoting
the expansion of british imperialism
besides if you think that this video is
intentionally ridiculous
you're probably right but this isn't
nearly as bad as
actual reality look at this tweet
look at it this is a real tweet by a
real human on twitter
that actually claims that using the word
waifu is
racist and misogynistic i won't show the
username on screen because i don't want
to be accused of cyberbullying but take
my word for it this is a serious tweet
by a real person imagine claiming that a
word that japanese people themselves
invented and use on a regular basis as
an english loanword
is racist towards those same japanese
people
and then imagine claiming that using
this word to describe your favorite
fictional female anime character is
sexist and misogynistic
and you thought that being offended over
pokemon sword and shield before the game
even comes out is ridiculous
please get woke if you enjoyed this
video leave a like subscribe and share
with all of your woke friends
if you want to help me monetize my
completely unjustified outrage then
become an anime outpro activist and give
me money on patreon
the more money that i get on patreon
from this video the more things i will
find to be offended about
on your behalf as always thank you so
much for watching and until next time
see ya
space vegan people kind
[Music]
you